faut être entouré pour vous aider à
booster dans les moments où ça les vapes
des conseils en pleine séance de massage
des gestes accompagné de bons mots un
échange indispensable pour maeva 54 ans
qui domaine entamera sa première séance
de chimiothérapie
c'est une très belle rencontre j'ai vu
c'est en fait je suis j'ai connu
floriane par par rapport à mon
infirmière de danon et on a besoin
d'être aidé parce que c'est dans les
connu on ne sait pas comment expliquer
c'est quelque chose de nouveau bond ont
dû toucher massage pour se réapproprier
son corps des soins ont qu esthétique
pour pallier les transformations
physiques
les bénévoles de l'association atout moa
que chaque mois une vingtaine de
patients aux profils multiples c'est au
type de patients hommes comme femmes
quel que soit l'âge quelle que soit la
situation professionnelle c'est vraiment
le patient qui a besoin d'être écoutés
et d'avoir les conseils nécessaires pour
mieux supporter des traitements est âgé
d'une cinquantaine d'années après une
mammographie réalisée en début d'année
une terrible nouvelle est venue troubler
sa vie jusque là plutôt tranquille
c'est un cancer du sein ça a été
découvert au mois de janvier donc
l'opération à une bulle au mois d'avril
et la première chimio va commencer
demain
donc c'est à propos ce soin de bien être
aujourd'hui temps de traîne qui tombe
bien la cage nerfs a du mal à dissimuler
son émotion d'autant qu'elle devra
répéter une séance de chimio tous les 20
jours
arnaud membre de l'association atome ou
lui proposent une séance de détente à
partir de fauteuil médicalisé eu de
contacts très sensible donc en rien que
de toucher simplement le dos ou lapin en
temps normal même sans avoir
d'expérience de massage on peut détendre
quelques uns au delà de ça c'est des
personnes qui ont une vie de famille
donc ils viennent déposer sa si vous
voulez ici et puis elle se donne le
temps fait des personnes qui s'adonnent
le tampon elle-même dans les murs de
l'unité de soins palliatifs de clarac 11
lits sont réservés aux patients atteints
de cancer ici les traitements sont
parfois lourds l'arrivée des soins de
support ravi une partie du corps médical
on sait l'effet qu'un état psychologique
sur une maladie et
on parle souvent des défis
psychosomatique donc il faut que le
patient soit bien dans sa tête dans son
corps dans son dans sa spiritualité pour
pouvoir avancer dans la vie et pour
pouvoir lutter contre la maladie le
cancer c'est pas fun grippe ce qui
accompagne chaque jour les patients dans
l'unité de soins palliatifs de clarac
sont tous des bénévoles les membres de
l'association atout mots sont des
professionnels de santé qui de l'avis
des patients pour leur métier par
vocation